nos piden encontrar las intersecciones
en x de esta ecuación donde más un
tercio de x 12 y usarlas para graficar
esta recta recordemos que la
intersección en x
es el punto en la gráfica que se
encuentra sobre el eje x ni arriba ni
abajo de él por lo que nuestro valor es
cuando ya es igual a cero y usando
exactamente el mismo criterio para la
intersección en la vamos a tener cuando
la línea toque exactamente el eje y es
decir cuando x es igual a 0 usemos esto
en la ecuación que nos dan para
encontrar las intersecciones así que
para encontrar la intersección en x
tenemos que poner ya en ser de esta
ecuación así que aquí será 2 x ya que es
0 más un tercio de x igual a 12 2 por 0
0 así que nos queda un tercio de x
igualados aquí pues podemos multiplicar
todo por el recíproco de un tercio de
manera que el recíproco de un tercio es
tres entre uno puede multiplicar esto
por tres entre uno y de este otro lado
también hacemos lo mismo para que se
conserve la igualdad y con esto esto se
van y me queda que x es igual a 12 x 336
entre 1 pues queda igual 36 éste
es mi intersección en x va a ser el
punto 36,0 ahora para la intersección en
y bueno aquí nos dicen que es cuando x
es igual a cero así que en esta ecuación
sustituimos x con 0 y la resolvemos 2
más un tercio de x que es cero igualados
bien esto es un 0 nos queda 2 igual a 12
dividimos todo entre 2 esto entre 2 y
esto entre 2 nos va a quedar igual a 2
entre 26 muy bien nuestra coordenada de
la intersección ya va a ser cero
recordamos x es 06 vamos a dibujar estos
puntos voy a tratar de hacer una gráfica
aquí lo más derechita que se pueda lo
bueno es que esto tiene herramientas
bastante útiles entonces va a ser este
mi
de la siesta aquí voy a dibujar mi eje
de las x le voy a hacer más larga porque
el valor mx es mayor a esta le ponen sus
etiquetas
x
y nos dicen la intersección en x es 36
cómo hacer vamos a hacer grupos de 6 o
saltos de 6 6 12 18 24 30 y 36 entonces
aquí los etiquetas 6 12 18 24 30 y 36 y
también hago el para de las divisiones
bueno porque vemos que el 6 más o menos
está por acá y el 12 estaría más o menos
por acá bueno entonces nuestra
intersección en x que lo dibujamos en
color como verdecito 36 036 es este
justo tocando el eje x y nuestra
intersección en 0 6 0,6 justamente acá
así que mi línea de esta ecuación va a
pasar más o menos por acá
voy a hacer que se toquen estos dos
puntos aquí así y voy a tratar de
continuar lo de acá acá más o menos ahí
está esta es la línea que me describe
esta ecuación de acá y sólo nos falta
poner las coordenadas de los puntos de
estas intersecciones aquí es 36 036 0 y
el de ayer justo cuando la línea toca al
eje y es el punto 0,6 y con esto hemos
resuelto este problema